哈喽各位同学大家晚安
听得到我吗?理论上应该OK啦
来咯那今天的课程主题是这个
是跟这个老大哥有关
孙子兵法
但是政客会在十几分钟后才会开始
然后呢今天的美股
是我记得是感恩节修士的
所以你看今天的美股
根本就是基本上是不会动的
所以你可以不用理他了
那我们先来看一些别的东西
那今天我有做了一些黄金
那个在这边等一下也可以拿我自己这些的交易来跟大家聊一下
我们先来看同学的东西
来从最上面开始好了
同学吃Adobe
小时可以破底翻有吃一些部位
好,我们来看一下同学的Adobe
他最近好像刚出一个那个什么Photoshop
的免费版怎么样子
然后一年免费还是什么
大家如果需要可以去
去吃,不是吃啦,去download
那你说你在小10k,我们看一下
这个很清楚啊
我猜你的边界应该是在这边,对不对
接下來想等日線才會繼續把部位吃滿
價格在週線下緣
我覺得你吃的還算不錯
我們看週線
等一下喔
週線
這個週線的邊界不錯
但是
本週可惜了點
我大概知道你吃的概念
其實就是週線這樣子
那我的建議是如果你看到週線
不要
不要用小10k 60分k去配到周线那么大
你会有点失去的焦点
我的建议是
如果你要你的大刻度是周线
你中间其实你用日线来做
这样就够了
所以对日线来说
日线可能还要再多等一下下
就像你讲的
多等一个比较明确的样子出来
会比较好做
这样好不好
然后呢
GME
來 GME 的話上週買在20.5,停損設在19.5目標價然後想等一個亞當大概到23
這個GME如果你用這個週限來看
上週你買的位置是很漂亮的位置喔
開拍手,這是個很好的點
那你說預計等到亞當23塊
这很OK
这个周线很OK
那如果
我跟你说
如果真的23块到了
这样看起来
短线的这个边会震荡一下
那如果震荡后再到23块
很值得出一流一
就是因为它的
如果到那边的周线
其实应该会长这样子
如果到这边
周线会长这样子
对不对
那很值得等待一些震荡
然后把这个周线一路翻到25以上
这个位置
这样子
所以在这个地方
你出一半我觉得很OK
下一个出场位置就是什么
就是上面这一堆
很多人套牢的这些地方
这样你的
你的这个计划我觉得不错啊
好
然后呢
请问老鱼若设完停立
人还在盘前
这个我把它截图起来好了
看到一堆上引线
会提早收子弹吗
来这个不是一个绝对会或绝对不会的题目
我举我自己为例好了
如果是我自己
例如说我本来预计
假设我预计
我用黄金
来
对我自己的黄金
这边到这里
我原本预计是做到哪里
是做到更上面去
然后我中间想一想
不对耶
今天美股如果休息
那其实没有做交易的人会变多
不做交易的人变多
那就是交易量变少的概念
那交易量变少
要冲出去是不是比较不容易
然后我又看到一些上影
好啦好啦出一出
然后又是前面这些地方
那我这样子的想法会有前提是
第一个我处在
我举个例子
我用小那当例子
好了,小娜的例子比较简单
例如说小娜在
今天的5分可以看到都是在这里,对不对但如果你拉到长线来看,你发现小纳就是在在60分k的满足区那你60分k的满足区我根本就不太想要再继续报很长线的单子
因为他前面已经长一大段了
所以我中间如果看到短线上不去
我可能原本是意气做更上去的
就发现不对他在这里就上不去
好啦好啦出一出
这个时候我会做一个心理建设
因为我是不是决定短线出场
像我刚刚那个黄金一样
如果我自己决定短线出一出
我看到上影线
我也真的亲眼看到了
也真的变弱了
我相信了他
我就不要去去在乎
去眷恋另外一套剧本
就是一路喷的剧本
因为我可能本来预计要做到100
结果我到80
就自己决定出场
好啦好啦出场
对吧
那我就要接受
这个当下我已经换成了一套
在80出场的计划
那100的计划
我就要被80出场
就没有100的计划了
很多人在这个瞬间会乱掉
是因为
如果待会行情跑到100
他会开始自责
我怎么每次都这样子
我下次应该要怎么样怎么样
然后你就会开始去找
更多行情前面的迹象
就是已经发生的迹象
哎呀原来均线这么漂亮
我应该抱着的
哎呀原来KD指标怎么样怎么样
还没到80我应该抱着的
你所有的这些想法
全部都是事后论
所以在那个当下
你要改变计划OK改啊
接受台语讲欢喜感欢
就是爽啊出场
OK那出场之后
拜托出场之后就不要再看了
所以我有一个建议给大家
如果你是像这样子
你本来要做出去
到中间就获利出场
那出场之后
你给自己一个
大概30分钟的冷却时间
这个冷却时间很重要
因为其实现在可以吃一些
今天没有开盘
但是这边好像还不错
好啦 反正今天
今天有子弹
玩一下
才画240而已那我的意思是假如举个例子假设我这个单子我吃在这个地方我防守在这里我最衰就是按下去
待会就蹦就打下来
让我停顺掉
对不对
那如果
我预计来到
我预计要做到东东翻亚当出去
我可能要做到348
这样子
我要从300做到348
赚50点
那如果我来到这边
发现长了一堆上影线像这种
像这样子的样子
来到这里
那我就要做一个抉择啦
留还是走还是出一半
三个计划嘛
要嘛全部留要嘛全部走
那很简单的动作就是
当行情来到这个地方
就稍微再上来一点点
我就会把我的风险
拉到我的成本价
哎就不赔了
那不会赔钱之后呢
剩下就是老天爷的事
我就可以很轻松的持有我的出场计划
如果我看到这边的出现上影线
我预计要出
那我就不要回头
就是出场之后
出场之后我就不要回头去检讨说
出场之后到底是涨上去
哎呀还是怎么样
不关我的事
我就冷却个30分钟
那我刚刚说冷却30分钟有好处
什么好处
来
如果你在这边出场
待会儿
跑到这里来
那你在这里出场嘛
出场之后
行情30分钟后再回来看
就两件事情
要么直接喷到你的目标价
你也错过了
错过了你反而会比较宽心
反正你也没机会进场
对不对
要么就跌下来
哎不错跌下来这样子
对不对
所以你不会急着想要再把刚刚的部位
再重新打进去还怎么样子
你就隔个30分钟
那个能下单的时间点
如果他中间还有回来又喷出30分钟后
能下瞻的时间点也错过了
那你也没关系
反正就错过了
你就反而也不会急
最忌讳的是那种出场之后
然后还待在盘前一直看出
我这里是不是这样比较好
这样这样这样这样
你要犹豫到什么时候
一犹豫就没了啦
这样好不好
好
好那看一下同學的這個什麼廣運6125
我們看一下廣運巨大條我聊一下
巨廣運在哪裡
我剛好叫出來在這
有同学问说
他是6125的周线
这两天都在吃吃吃
不知道会不会拉肚子
来
如果以周线来说
本周今天周四
本周先不要看
来我问一下
眼前的各位
特别是这位
这位FENG分同学
在这周的前一周
周线的样子长什么样子
很凶
还是有长这种
这种下影线停顿样子的周线
哪一种是这样子吗
还是很凶
其实是蛮凶的
对不对
所以这一周才是很凶以后的第一次停下来
对吧
那这个第一次停下来
我会认为不用到太急着吃
好不好
你等他真正周线出现关键的十字以后
你再来出手
后面再来规划打击区
再来出手
一点都不急
但如果你是想说反正我有资本
我切十等份
就这些资本就算亏掉了
我其实我的钱都还蛮有充裕的感觉
那是另外一件事
因为那个是比较有资本人在做的事
承受得起风险的人在做的事情
那如果是这样子
那你的打击区就是要宽宽的
宽宽的
就是62也好
62.7也好
你不能手短短的
你会把自己逼死
这样好不好
所以慢慢来
可以慢慢吃
以长线来讲
但是你心中要有底
这个图其实还没有到很美
尤其是注意看
平平的斜斜的
各位你看到什么东西
所以你要心里有个底
是可能下一周还会
本周或下一周还会再往下一些些
这个几率其实
相形之下
是比较高的
这我们过去看的经验
如果今天这一周
是出现这种
这种
例如说假设
这周变这样子
我会跟你说
下一周眼睛闭着随便吃
对在这种地方
很好防守
又好防守又好进攻
太棒了就是那个下引线的
那个十字线
這樣好不好
然後呢中美金6411我现在看到什么
我的单子我等一下会拿出来讲
等一下我的那个黄金我会拿出来聊
今天的修饰是
今天的现货修饰
然后期货通常就是会提早收盘
这样
然後我看一下1519周限
我看一下1519
這個周限
周限問什麼
是不是還沒
我有沒有看錯
一點都不美
你說老於
所以你說這個不是互換嗎?
這個支撐壓力互換
來來來來
周宣我這樣問你好了
這個壓力支撐互換
這個互換的動作
它發生在區間的上、中、還是下
哪一個?
這個或是這邊
這種發生在哪裡?
下面的滿足區這種地方
而眼前的這個呢?
對吧?
然後再來
除了是大刻度的视角以外
另外我带你看一下
这边你说你可能有互换
你可能有互换
但是你没有看到对面
对过来
这么多人卡在这上面
不要当勇者
不要不要
我们要在市场上当
不勇敢的老大
真正在战争的时候
老大都是躲后面的
没有人像那个电影一样
那个有主角光环
美国队长
然后我就觉得敌人很笨
美国队长的盾牌就这么大一个而已
然后他的敌人就一定要对盾牌射
就不会射他的脚
这搞不懂
这就是电影
好不好
所以真实世界
我们不要当那个
冲在最前面的那个小兵
你只是人家垫被踩上去的东西
不要啦
所以這個我會完全的放掉
然後中美金中美金,中美金相對起來來來來看一下同样是周线这个周线就是做空的人一直下不去的边界
讲中美金的这位同学
相对起来你看好多了
有没有
对吧
然后中美金的同学
做100块防守95
目标150出掉
周线的计划
我的建议是这样好不好
如果你吃在这种地方
对不对
你目前吃的点
我觉得应该都还不错
底下这里
那我的建议是
先不要到150
你来到这个地方
120到130之间
如果有机会
你先出个
你已经赚20%了嘛
你出个1%到1%的部位
我的建议是这样
为什么
因为这毕竟是一个
从2025年3月
到现在为止上不去的边界
所以下一次来到这边会有很多人
从三月到现在的人
每个都要解套
大家要解套
那这个解套自然就会变成在这边的什么
大震荡
所以150下一个门槛了
这样好吗
来那
还有
巨大
巨大巨大巨大巨大在这里
巨大昨天涨停
今天继续小涨一些些
对吧
那你說哇巨大怎麼漲停的
有人問我說我巨大吃回來了沒
我跟你說巨大底下這個邊界有沒有很漂亮
嘿嘿我有偷吃一些的
那只是偷吃一些還好啊
我覺得那個整個樣子就很漂亮
那個周線
哪知道吃了就上去
那如果你吃了以後
例如說假設你現在是空手
那有沒有關係
沒有關係啊
空手你就等啊等市场重新震荡出你看得懂的东西
这个100块到底是压力还是支撑
你就看他看他怎么做
初一留一之后把剩下的部分拉不赔
剩下的部分都一定要拉不赔
一定你都已经有机会让你出一半的部位
代表你已经有赚超过某个程度的利润
你剩下的部位当然是用不赔跟他换
再回答个几个问题然后我们再来跟大家聊然后有同学说做TQQQ上面有看到什么?TQQQ怎么样?
吃在45.8,出在53
哦!朝圣!
耶!太厉害了
然后TQQQ很简单
同学吃的位置
对吗 周线的边界嘛 对不对 哇太棒了
如果我是你 我不会出光光 我可能会留一些 因为我这么强大的下影线
那他这个上去很有可能继续往上去挑战上面的这个东西
好不好
11月21跌破397把他卖掉 结果又涨回去 有做错吗
我不知道你的成本在哪里
特斯拉你的成本我不知道
我的特斯拉是回来
我就是吃
我的想法就是这样
我不知道你的成本
我不知道你的交易计划
所以你说
跌破397的边界
跌破这个边界
你讲的应该是这里
11月21号
21号
21号在哪里
我怎么叫不出这个
我没有叫出图例来
我很少用这个
时间与销售
好像也不是这个
不要理我
21号是哪一天
所以你讲应该是
这是17
我不太懂
为什么你吃在这边
你没有守的是守这种地方
如果你是日线图的话
他不是
不是一个
你讲的应该是
还是你说的是这样子以后跌破这里
那可能就是更短刻度的事情
我看一下
好那我再猜你应该是吃在这
按照这样来看397在这里
那我猜你是在这边
上去后拉不赔跌破
把它卖掉OK啊
跌破卖掉了然后就
重来就好了
顶多这里有新的重来啊
各位这什么图
这个
这不是破底番吗
对吧
你说我的TESDA怎么做
我的TESDA不是做短线
我还记得我在
我在一年
一年前我还跟大家说我看可不可以抱他个一年
看会发生什么事
所以我并没有打算做短线的
我做短线的是之前的像什么QS
这种我在16块17块这边出掉
这就是我都有贴给大家看
然后像这种我就是短线来来回回把它做
Tesla 那个是我预计就是继续的
继续的抱着的
好嗎?
那我再看個兩支股票
讓我先聊一下今天的東西
然後順便我們中間都會切回來看股票的地方
然後來聊一下
3234看一下
這其中一支322
我看到什麼就講什麼好不好?
拜託不要怪我說沒看到你的
3234這破底翻好美喔
真的好美
光环破底翻后往上喷
这怎么会美成这样啊
哇这个边界干干净净
如果这不是破底翻
而且他还有这个
这个下影先在暗示你
这个很棒
现在就抱着啊
抱着啊
小目标已经达成了
因为已经到了压力
但是这个很值得抱什么
对抱一倍的距离出去
把亚当翻完
很不错很不错
有人问我说感恩节有吃烤鸡的习惯吗
没有
我没有吃烤鸡的习惯
因为我吃素十几年了
我们家人可能可以
看来准备要上去的
因为它越来越多下引线
甚至30分K
小时K都开始
土降好丑
重新整理一下
好 这样子
好 准备要上去了
好了 那就先留在这边
我们
我看一下台子
刚好像有人问我说台子期跟
台子夜盘跟海棋夜盘怎么看
不要交叉的看
你不要看美股做台股
不要看台股做美股
都不要
你做什么就看什么就好了
所有杂七杂八的都不要看
不然美股有三个
你看台子棋
美股有三个小道小那小SP你要追哪一个不要追啦看台子做台子旗就只需要看台子旗其他都是多的
都是杂讯
好不好
我看好像有说要看Adobe
对不对
Adobe我刚刚是不是有看过
对吧
Adobe在这里
你说什么时候吃
Adobe
吃在317是好点吗
昨天哦
昨天吃
昨天吃在
可以啦
我觉得没有什么问题啊
就边界在这边啊
差不多啦
他还没有到很标准的标准图
但是那个样子已经有点微微的出来的
我觉得还OK啦
好吗
那今天
今天让我先切回来正课
今天已经晚七分钟开始了
让我先切回来今天要讲的主题
待会再来跟大家聊
好不好
那刚刚有人问说
孙子真的是长这样吗
坦白说
我们眼前在看直播的每一个人
应该没有人知道
孙子、老子、孔子
他们长什么样
我说我只是觉得这些古人
长的每个都一样
都是这个样子
可能刘备的手画长一点点
这个看起来是耳垂很大
我不知道
这个图我是网路上Google找的
我也不知道今天
今天是谁
那我最早期
我不是看孙子兵法来做交易
我不是
我的交易法就自己摸一摸
就变这样子
那我是在看一部电影的时候
我看那个华尔街
我不知道大家有没有看过
那个华尔街的这个电影
不是新版的哦
新的近期
其实有拍他的续集
跟后来新的
我要看的是看1987年
麦克道格拉斯主演的《华尔街》的这部电影
那他里面
麦克道格拉斯他演的是一位
很资深很厉害的市场的大户
赚很多钱的那种大户
那他在某一个环节里面跟他的营业员说
说孙子兵法是很重要的书
要叫他去看
那他们讲的是
生住这样子
我就是他们讲
不是华尔街之狼
不是华尔街之狼虽然说华尔街之狼那部也很有娱乐性质好不好来对Gaggle没错就是他那片名
片名就叫华尔街
片名就是华尔街
Wall Street
很简单的片名
就1987年的这个
然后呢
来
我直接跟大家讲说
我很喜欢孙子兵法里面的
几个特定的章节
当然他全部都很棒
但是他这些章节是我很喜欢的东西
等一下会跟大家聊一下
然后我们就随便把我的小娜
哎呀上不去了耶
管他了反正才赔240还好啦
等一下我会拿我的单子来聊一下
大家不用担心
顺者必顽在哪
在这
来我们先把这些聊过去
要上国文课了要睡着了对不对
这句话应该是大家最耳熟能详的吧
知己知彼百战百胜这个
其实你这样回头想
知己知彼的意思是
我知道我在干嘛
那我也知道
对方的实力到哪里
对方弱了没
对方是不是还很强势
所以这句话其实涵盖了
他整篇这个孙子兵法里面
所有的东西
他的意思是
你不要什么都不知道
就闷着头就下去
但是很多人
在市场上做交易
就像我说了
有些散户就是
网路上某个大哥大姐
然后讲个几句话
你就跟着买股票
他说这个股票内线很棒
真的吗真的吗
就买了
你什么都不知道吧
对吧
所以你看他也说
为战要先干嘛
先计划好你的交易计划
你知道你要干嘛
最后才去吗
有人问我说
我会做空单吗
不会
我懒得做空单
而且我的脑袋没那么厉害
我的脑袋只能做一边的事情
其实我发现
单做一边的事情
好像就够了
我需要脑袋的留白
然后呢
他说
必时急需以义待劳
这就是我很喜欢的
这个观念
什么观念
例如说
今天的图
我觉得今天的行情
可能我被打掉的几率变高了
因为他这边越来越写了
我讲的以一代劳的概念是指
例如说
看这边看这边大家把事件看到这里来如果我要做多做多我做在这边跟做在这边哪一个比较好赚做在这边当然有可能继续往上喷
当然啊 对吧
但是人家是不是已经喷成这样子了
到底谁是易
谁是等在那边做的
谁是老
然后刚刚短线里面的这个震荡
超明确
来
做多的在这做空的人
杀到这里杀不下去杀不下去杀不下去
谁累了
然后对吧
做多的就趁对方累的时候就一路上去了
等一下我们还会继续的聊好不好
我们先来聊
这些东西都是我很喜欢的
然后什么攻其不备啦出其不易
他很喜欢玩什么
玩奇袭奇招让你想不到猜不透的这种东西
那在市场上其实也有
这句话我也很喜欢
因地至兵
依氏取利
简单的说
我们就是要占地利之变
我们小时候都有玩过那种
那种
网路上的游戏
手机游戏或电脑游戏
一格一格的战略
你的军队是
是那个什么
工兵
你的军队是水军
还是陆军还是寄兵
对吧
然后寄兵就很适合在平原走很远
寄兵跑到山上
他就只能走两步就被困住了
工兵就很适合躲在山里面
攻击力会增加等等
我们小时候玩的游戏里面
就隐含着这个概念
那市场上需不需要有
判断地形的这个地方
我们的第一个条件叫做位置
就是地形
刚刚不是有一个
一只股票
有一个同学找的一只股票
我忘记是哪一只的
有没有同学记得
那只股票在
在上面就是
好像是1519
是不是
对对对这只来来来
用这个当举例
以地形来说
这就是一个
不利我进攻的地形
我需要的是
很大的墙壁
在我的背后
那个城墙在帮我撑腰
但是眼前我却看到的是
对方的大城墙在这个地方
哇 这些七百五这边全部都是大城墙
那当然有可能冲上去
有可能冲不上去
那我的军队有没有累了
其实他们有展现出
冲上去被压下来
冲上去被压下来的样子
哇
跟我同一边
要一起往这边走的军队
怎么样
越来越没力了
我亲眼看到他越来越没力
所以是啦有援军啊
但是在这个地方援军进来
很有可能就是会
会被人家一网打尽
你知道吗
那我最喜欢反过来的事情
是什么
是当对方
做空的人进攻在底下
我最喜欢这种
做空的人冲
结果冲一次冲两次
冲不下去反被涨上来
结果反而这边有一个
这个来我们看这边
本来的这只股票我完全不认识他
本来的300多400块这个压力
本来的
这边
变成由上往下踩的什么
踩的地板
所以底下这群人是不是被困住了
我最喜欢等对方被困在下面
英文真的有
那个叫trapped trade
困在下面以后
我就放一把火
把他们都烧出来
这些人的停损被我逼出来
就会长在这个地方
好轻松愉快
就是这种感觉
然后把他们的粮食给断掉
不给他们援军
不让他们吃东西
他们就会饿死了
拼命的想要抢出来
对就是这样
市场就是战场
对吧
所以我后来把孙子兵法的东西拿出来看
我就觉得好棒
来那我们来聊一下
一些特别的东西
注意看
他说我们在打仗
是大家都出各种计谋
鬼道
他说你明明做得到
但是我要给你看我做不到
对吧
我可以用这个
但是要给你看说
我不用这个
对吧
很近的东西
我要特别告诉你
这很远
很远的我要告诉你
它很近
简单的说
我要骗你
他那个是的那个意思是指
我要让你以为
它是近的
以为它是远的
反正就是以为然后来很想赚钱的人就诱惑他對吧然後人家在亂七八糟的時候就取之
時而被之強而必之
人家很強的時候
例如說
很強勢的下殺
例如說像這個這個
這裡
看這裡
這一根是不是滿板很兇的K棒
很強的K棒
所以你要幹嘛
閃邊
對吧
对方很生气,对方很急着想做
嘿对,我就给他骚痒
好了,好了
旁边推一下,对哦,很棒哦
赶快做,赶快追,赞哦
对,回去了
所以从头到尾的这些
你们看到一些重要的事情
对方如果很安逸
我就让对方动起来
让他累
什么叫让他累
就让他走很远
让他走很远
让他累,累了以后
就换我们的军队
现在这个位置
尴尬了
是我们的军队
从南边走到北边
走得好远
的确走得好远
随时有可能有人
想家了你知道吗
随时有可能
有人想家说我不干了
我回家了丢下他的枪就回家了
也有可能是战败了
受伤了
又累又渴
又想上厕所
哇怎么办
对不对
所以
很好玩
对吧
再来
这些都是孙子兵法的东西
我是从网路上
其实你Google有孙子兵法的全文
然后说来哦
很善于用兵的人
能够让敌人前后接不起来
意思是
断掉他们的持续的援军
什么叫持续援军
底下这句话
什么东西
关门放狗
所以这里面所有的东西
你看
所以敌人整个都来了
我们要怎么办
先夺其所爱
人家爱的是什么
人家爱的是获利
例如说大军冲过来
先夺其获利
什么叫夺其获利
让这些要赚钱的人
例如说空在300块350的人
往上弹上去让他赚不了钱
那我的小娜呢
我的小娜被停损了好那我今天不干了来我跟大家讲这个系统有个很棒的东西就是这个Manual Lockout这个锁住All Day按下去
Lock
耶
今天
然后就会有锁住9个小时
这样子
我就可以避免我自己在接下来
把我今天吃的单子给赔掉
对不对
好
所以这边你大家自己去看
因为我们不是来做国文的解释的
所以我们整个文的样子就是什么
他们的士兵都散得到处都是
对吧
然后没有集中
兵虽然有合在一起
但是不整齐
所以有的人要做多
有的人做空
简单的说就是他们自己内部也乱掉
其实某个程度来说
台湾现在正在面临这种局面
大家加油一点
好不好
好
这些是他里面的一些说话的故事
我们仔细看一下
孙武是谁
孙武就是我们讲的孙子
他的全名就是孙武
你仔细看
如果敌人来打我们家这边
他问了
对方深入我的军队
这样子所以士兵都住在军队里面没有住在家里
然后呢我们的我们的兵呢都住在我们的大本营住在国里
很安全的很有斗志的对吧
所以在这种情形之下你要干嘛
你其实就是对方很累啊
所以他说你要干嘛来
这里很好玩哦
派出清兵
然后把他们的粮食给断掉
让他没东西吃
把他后面的粮草给截断
这不就是前一个
关门放狗又来了
我们又关门放狗一次
所以我觉得孙子很喜欢关门放狗
他很喜欢把对方设一个陷阱给你
就跟我们看三国志一样
草传借鉴一样
或是赤壁之战一样
我用个陷阱给你
把你全部都绑住
然后最后让你自己跳进去
门一关放一把火烧拜拜
是吧
你不觉得
这个就是孙武在讲的话很贼很贱但是却很好用在市场上面就是这么做所以我就让人家把人家关注
没东西吃
那你看如果这里
他说如果我自己的军队跑到对方的阵营里面
我们的军队是不是想要还乡
我们是不是好想家里的老公老婆
老婆,通常都是老婆
那个时候会有老公的吗
不知道
所以难进
易退
走很远
你的军队很累
很难再往前
很容易不小心就退一步
怎么办
所以你看
他就说我们到对面
他们都没有什么专心
所以不要在干嘛
你不要乱冲
然后所以你要用
可能要用计谋也好
要干嘛也好
所以你不要用冲的
所以以无以战为故
什么意思
无以尽其名城
这个好难看得懂
我其实也看不太懂
我跟大家讲
我以前的国文是被荡掉的那种
看我字写很丑就知道了
但是我大约可以抓得出来说
那他的想法就是
如果是这样子
我们要怎么做
所以简单的说
我直接抓结论
让对方累
我们是处在一个准备的
很好吃的饱饱的
然后很有体力的状态去跟对方打
各位如果有看棒球
曾经有一年的我们的那个经典赛
赛前的这些赛在台湾打的
我们的那个赛前的赛程台湾队
被排晚接早
就今天晚上打完
隔天早上一早又要再打一场国际赛这样子
你觉得这样对体力的负荷大不大
超恐怖的啊
这怎么打啊
对吧
那如果对方是好好的休息了一整天
然后我们这个军队都没有休息的时候
谁容易赢谁容易输
这个一看就知道了
对不对
然后呢
他说
人家的军队很强的时候要干嘛
来人家军队哇好强哦
他们好多人哦怎么办
他说什么
我们先等一下对吧
顺其
所以对方很凶,我们先干嘛,你很凶,给你,给你,这个战场给你,我不要跟你争,你太凶了,你太厉害了,不要,不要,所以不可争锋,不要跟他冲,我们闪一边,干嘛,等他凶完了,等对方干嘛,以意其懈怠,等他们累了,他们凶完了,他们气消了,我们再开始慢慢的出来,
哦
而这个动作就是我们讲的原地停顿的下影线
是吧
所以你如果用这种角度来看
很多时候
老鱼你被打掉了
我刚刚就说我是
想说仗着今天有利润随便吃的
今天我不打算再做
因为待会会提早收盘
各位其实今天就不要做了
好不好
我们要讲的概念是你放在
例如说任何东西
我们讲的原地停顿的下影线
我们举个例子
例如说航海王我们的长戎
在当时这个是不是一个原地停顿的下引线
是只是他引线真的有够长
但是他有没有构成这个概念
就是这个引线杀下去但是被救援成功
有所以后面这个边界出来以后就容易出去
但是你看哦
身為做多的人
衝到這邊去
是不是做空的人越來越容易出手做空的地方
所以我就不要在這種地方去跟他拼
市場就這樣下來
而最近 我們看最近就好了
眼前的長榮
你應該看得出來
周線他處在哪裡
他處在大顆度的下緣
短線的短線的圖其實也沒有很漂亮
他还在这边扫来扫去
但是我只知道他长线是这个样子的
在前一段时间10月这边他有一根K棒
这个
我们来看一下哦从这边下杀到这里的过程中
杀杀杀杀杀突然间出现这根
下不去了
他是第一个透露出176到178这边
有人
有大户在顾的这个意图
而这个意图就是我们讲的
对方累了对方其实也做空的人也是拼命的往下杀没错但是他累了所以我们就等等什么他累了之后我们再出手
这就是我们那个尖尖的的由来
对吧
然后这个动作
它是不是就是我们讲的位置观性图的惯性
所以其实前面很多地方都在讲
讲位置对吧
所以你看哦
把孙子兵法
我没有讲全部的孙子兵法
大家可以自己去看
我只是把其中里面
我觉得几个很棒的点
包含
我们要先站到地利之变
先在这个地方
以意代劳的等对方累
所以我们要先跑到定点
在这里等
我们不是要
好累
刚跑到这个地方
急着就要赶快再做下一个动作
好累
没有
我们是
你被穿后搬一张椅子坐在那边等你
等你在眼前变累
那后面的市场就是我的
如果你有去看那个我刚刚讲那个华尔街的电影
麦克道格拉斯主演的那个
他里面的做法就是
大户先在底部都先吃好了
他吃到他要的选择权
他要的股票
然后呢他干嘛了
他就开始打电话
他讲一串术语
专门的术语
什么术语
他告诉对方这一串话
什么Horseshoe
我其实忘记了
忘记他的真正的全文是什么
总之他就讲一段话
对方就知道
那个营业员就知道说
他买好了
可以打电话给营业员的其他客户
叫其他客户来买了
你想他在10块钱买好
营业员一打电话
张大哥
我跟你说这只股票我有内线
这个以后一定超棒超棒的
赶快买赶快买
你现在不买我跟你说你会后悔的
张大哥买了100万
然后于大哥也买了100万
王大哥也买了100万
打给好多人
每个人都这样讲
打10个有5个买单
哇太好了
买的人是不是越来越多
然后他又可以打给其他的营业员
我们大家一起赚
一个人打给10个客户
然后再打给10个
再打给10个
所以大家就开始上
然后就开始涨了
这时候来刚刚打电话听到这些消息的客户们有的人买的有的人没买对不对买的的人会不会很开心哇 感谢你你给我这个内线消息真的涨了
对吧
他会不会在干嘛
他会不会在买
如果你是那个底下的人
哇 涨了
哇 再买一些
你知道你为什么想要再买吗
因为你贪
哎呀 我只买100 不够
再100 再200
因为你认为说
如果我当初买个300
赚个10%起来就30万
可恶我只买100
没关系追
那这追的都是买单
那这些买单又会刺激新的人涨上去
刚刚没有买的人又觉得这个地方没有买
很可惜
他又买上来
所以就是你买
我买
你买
追
底下的大户
底下大户在干嘛
可能还不见得会出
因为可能还在他的成本附近
才刚出来一些
等大家都一直追了追了追了追上去
对
他就开始干嘛
出货
他出货会跟你说吗
说我要出货了
不会
他就是
他如果跟你讲
你比他早一步出货
你是不是把他的价格给吃掉了
对吧
所以他要做的事情就是偷偷的默默的吃
偷偷的默默的把上面的部位都出掉了
然后他都出的时候还要一直叫你来买
因为他才有办法出在越来越高的价格
就是这样子啊
那你说电影里面的手法
是不是照着巴菲特大户的缩影
我不知道巴菲特有没有这么凶狠
但是巴菲特在底下是吃饱是没错
但是市场上面
几乎每一个这种大基金大法人的大户们
他们其实都是在做同一件事
就是底下买
他不会让你知道
他让你知道上电视上新闻的时候
就是他已经买好了
可能他要买一亿的部位
他已经买好了七八千万了
好了可以开始炒作
留一些等候面加码用
大概是这样子
他先买好他的部位
市场上就是这样玩而已
没有其他的动作了
然后你说他们会不会追会
有些时候他会先追给你看
他先敲门追出去
他底下找就大部位买好了
上面买个一百张两百张
他买给你看说有人在追
有人追旁边那些散户们
很容易受到情绪驱动的散户们就一个追两个追然后就上去了就是这样哦好不好那部电影是我很喜欢的一部电影
这样
OK
你说听起来很像诈骗吗
某个程度来说在市场上面
大家就是耳于我诈
就是在把对方的钱骗到我的手上
我很认真的讲的
我现在不是在乱讲的
期货更明显
股票市场其实也是
就是叫你去追
可能你会赚到一些钱
如果你懂得出
可能会赚到一些钱
但是大户的目的
你有没有赚钱
那已经不重要
重点是你追了
帮他把价格垫上去
有燃料
那就是一直上去
他底下早就吃饱了
前几年
有一次郭台铭宣布
他要参选总统
记得吗
在参选总统那时候
一宣布
当时的鸿海
我记得在70块那边
盘整了好久
但是跌到70就有人吃
跌到70就有人吃
那个日线图超明显
你自己去看鸿海当时的样子
结果他一宣布要选总统
哇 突然间涨到100多块
选总统的那天就整个这样喷上去
哇 结果呢
后来他有没有选
没有啊 后来不选了
所有的这一切
当然当时追的人现在回头看都赚钱
但是他中间又回来好一段时间
我要讲的是
后来才被大家发现
这个网路上都有数据
你有新闻的
郭台铭在参选之前
底下他自己就在吃
这个都有资料的
大家自己去找
所以他自己就在底下吃
然后才宣布在选总统
对吧
所以我都觉得这些都是商人
好不好
难怪有钱越来越有钱
是啊
这个没有办法
他们也这一切都合法
因为他告诉你说
这股票超棒的
来
是谁决定要买下去的
是谁
是你呀
是你自己决定要按下去的
那按下去的那一瞬间
你就不要怪别人跟你讲
这是股票的好坏
对吧
是你自己要按的
那你就要接受
你要接受这个风险
接受这个利润
对吧
如果你所有的风险都不想接受
那该得的利润
你自然就拿不到
市場上這個盈虧是同源是共生的
這樣好嗎
然後小納喔對阿小納直接問一下
没错没错川普吃饱
我都觉得川普当总统的目的
是来做股票的
我真的这样觉得
因为他每
而且他都会自己喊很少有股
不是不是很少
从来没有一个总统可以这么直接的在
在网络上喊说我觉得美股会涨
对不对
好吧
来
所以整个孙子兵法看下来
不外乎就是这三件事情
位置惯性图
位置在哪里
你要以意待劳
地形偏
你先到这个位置等他
对吧
等对方变累
然后惯性呢
惯性就是我们刚刚讲的
如果K棒下来
满满的大K棒
我们要干什么
等什么
等原地停顿的这个
那原地停顿的这个
来
一张图形
一个行情这样子
上上下下
如果
这个行情跑到这里来
下影线这张图长在这里
我一点都不会理它
我不喜欢它长在这
那我喜欢的下影线是长在哪里
边界在这边
我喜欢它长在破了以后
破边界以后的这个隔壁
这个是我很爱的
最近有个同学好像有吃到这个部位
那个叫什么
ATOM
有一个网友
他说他吃在这个边这里
边界二这里
各位来来来来
我放大
这是不是就是我们讲的
这里就是我们的打击区
他说要吃在这边
结果就从两块涨到2.4多
然后我自己有吃一个
我本来还想要多吃一些
你看一下
这是我刚吃的
我应该讲昨天刚吃的部位
我吃的点在哪
我吃的点在这
这里
我就看下不去
日线
他日线就很美
日线就在这里
在一大堆
一大堆下影线
下不去下不去的这个边界
好好吃一下
我吃不多
我才吃3000穀而已
我其实原本预计要3000
3000慢慢的这样吃
我也不知道吃了
他就上去
可恶
常常这样子
很可恶
对吧
我的确就是在做这种事情
那我吃在
我做多在这里我是不是做多在再一个我看周线应该会比较清楚我是不是做多在周线很下面的地方我没有做多在9块钱8块5
那你说当时有没有人买在这边
有啊当时冲的咧
来我们看一下当时
来
这是小时k
连续几个小时来到这里
对吧结果呢
来
撞 各位请问一下
上影线 上影线 这什么意思
所以这一次
再度撞在这边的这些人
这些人他心里在想什么
他们想的是不是 他买在8块钱 他要赚到16块
买8 赚到10块 16块赚钱
对不对
所以要干嘛
他们就追 追了以后
没有一个人赚钱
我追了以后,哇!开始掉下来
各位有没有看到这边开始变成一个干干净净的边界
然后留下几个上影线
突出去在这个干净边界的以内以外
以外完蛋了,这些人被关门了
他们的军队从底下这边长到这边长这么多
对吧,没有援军了怎么办
就下來了
瞬間從這小時哦
幾個小時之後
從這邊7塊多跌到
不要講幾個小時這兩個就好了
這個小時跟這個小時
兩個小時從7塊多跌到3塊
哭不哭
很慘耶
啊
追在這邊有沒有任何好處
沒有
承受的風險那麼大
随时有可能拉回
你眼前又是这种人家各种在卖的墙壁
这是最笨的啊
那你反过来哦
你用
你用那个做多的角度来想
做多的军队冲
买
啊没力的
再冲一次买
请问你这个军队
有能力征服这个城墙
变成一个做多的
上影线的那个大K棒上去吗
他有征服吗
没有耶
他是盘中撞上撞上去
结果又被神秘力量压回来再撞一次哇又被压回来结果这次连撞都撞不上去直接就压回来了我们看到这个动作
那这不就是做多的军队
累了
空方大本营从这一根开始
他们就开始发现
做空的有在这边集结
复仇者联盟的那个集结
有集结在这边
撞上去被压回来
赞喔
对吧
所以就是这个概念
这样而已
所以
我只是想说
他在下面
很下面
这样子吃
我哪知道他会上去
那我吃的概念
是不是反过来
做空的军队
打下来都被买上去
这个边界都有人用
你大概懂这个意思吧
我是不是做在对方的反过来
然后这个刚刚我同学说要吃
要看那个SMCI
我短线你吃在这里
但是我不是看短线吃
我是看日线就直接吃
有人说要怎么显示出这个
来
你看这个
查看这里有一个已完成交易的标记
这个你可以把它打开
你看像我关掉
关掉就没有了
没有箭头
打开
它就有箭头
就有这个
但它最多只能显示7天的
所以就是你
你七个日期
日历天
七天以内它都还显示得到
七天以后的就看不到了
它就是这样子
OK
然后呢
你看哦
眼前的这个
来请问你
你有没有看到各种下影线
各种下影线
甚至这个小时可以很清楚
有没有
这个边界
尤其是最近来看
这个边界越来越从本来的压力
答还有点破
但是越来越不破
这是个好事
对吧
有人说这样算撞墙吗
位阶很美
这个位阶
你看周线的位阶
看一下周线
这位阶很美
很美
老玉你是拗了
对啊我拗
但是因为拗的钱
相对起就是我的资本来讲
那个钱是很可以负担的这样讲好了好不好所以我在吃的时候某个程度来说我现在的吃法又有点不同我有点综合的就是有钱加上
没有资本的综合体
前面我先丢一些钱先试单
反正这个亏损都可以承受
完全我现在里面的钱
我现在里面丢多少
丢6万8而已
我这6万8全部赔掉
ok赔了拜拜
所以其实还好
所以就变成是我自己
对于这个金钱的刻度
已经跟以前最一开始的时候不太一样
这样好不好
那如果你是新手同学
你现在再开始吃就好了
对吧
我的做法就可以
我可以分一些资金
左半边先随便吃一些
等行情回来
右半边再吃一些
大概就是这样子
ok
像我的特斯拉
我特斯拉市场价值现在20万
味食先4万
我大概吃了就16万
所以其实这些都还好
6万8是美金
我用的这个是IB
就是盈透证券
这个是直接开国外的
所以眼前你这边看到的
这些都是美金
这不是台币
所以变成
客户要练
我跟你说
不要觉得说
老鱼你科度好大
拜托 科度比我大的比比皆是
我要讲的是
我做得到
各位也做得到
你不用急
它是会慢慢的
你的科度会慢慢的起来的
你的生活上平常也需要练习
把你生活上的科度
从CP值
你买东西
做事情都在考虑
那个CP值的脑袋拿掉
你要考虑的
不能一直从CP值来出发
好不好
这样
OK
早几年有重心都在期货上
对啊早几年
因为当时的资金也还没有
比较没有起来
后来从期货赚到一些钱之后
我能够丢股票的资本就越来越多
然后能够丢股票资本越来越多
其实我很喜欢做长线的股票
你知道为什么吗
因为我做期货我需要看着盘
然后我才能够做得到
如果我今天
例如说某一段期货喷出了
我没有做到
下午喷我没做到
那一整天大概就只有那个点
但是我如果做股票
我可以把时间刻度拉很长
我甚至可以去度假
度个一个礼拜的假
回来我的股票还在
甚至还多走了一段路
所以我很喜欢这种
长线的部位是可以让我兼顾生活
兼顾我的工作
兼顾我的家庭
还有我的运动
我喜欢打棒球
这些都可以兼顾
所以我很爱这样子
OK
然后
这在讲老婆的贴物吗
你们有追哦
厉害哦
的确
其实我跟我老婆的金钱观念很多是
是很像的
然后
这个很像不是一开始就很像
也是慢慢慢慢大家沟通
聊天
然后观念会慢慢的会磨合在一起
所以我们认为很多东西是
你该用就用
例如说一个LV的包包
10万块钱
就觉得好贵
包包3000块就有了
为什么要拿一个10万块的包包
因为我觉得值得
这就是差别
我觉得它值得好用
一用可能用个10年
那可以
所以我就不是
不完全都是用CP值的角度去看
然后这个Peter同学
他说波音ARM漂亮
ARM是什么东西
看一下
那你说老爷
你怎么看到这么多漂亮的股票都没有吃
一方面是因为现在美股开盘
真的都10点半才开
然后可能10点半不见得有我要的位置
随便弄一弄就11点了
那我已经很习惯
就是到10点半后
我的整个心思跟脑袋已经变成是
是跟老婆躺在床上
随便找个Netflix看一下
然后准备睡觉的这种样子
这样
所以我很不喜欢动令时间
对
所以我就是
放很轻松
有就随意吃一下
没有就算了
这样子
来
台泥月线
我会挨忧吗
台泥
月我先跟所有同学说我从来没有看过月线我了不起看过周线所以你说的月哦
我第一次按
哦有啦
月线这个尖尖的很明确啦
这真的很明确
我会IU吗
会耶
但是你看哦
11月27号今天
所以在三天四天
这个月月底这样
然后12月
等于说12月
我有一整个月的时间可以吃
那我就不用挤啊
那我就可以在后面
其实我可以好好地规划说
如果周线上去又回来
这边
那这会是一个很棒很棒的破底翻的点
那这样子可能几周上去几周回来
说不定刚好让月线出现在隔壁下个月这样
那这个日线图跟周线图
现在的位置都不漂亮
它都是在撞墙
现在不要在这里追
现在要等
好点已经过了
好点不在这种
不在这个22.1这里
因为现在就撞这里了
不好做
然后呢
BMNR
这什么东西
这个吗
刚过
什么东西刚过
Bitmine
日线
日线能做的点
对啊
刚过
现在
现在尴尬了点
现在有点
稍微追了点
如果是这样
尤其是像这种
来注意看
这种
这样下来的这个
只要这边不是这种
尖尖的下引线
这种
我的
我的动作都会缓一点
你要吃
你就缩小部位
不要一次就把你的钱
全部进去
这样
好不好
然后我上面看到什么
我就随便随便看
NVIDIA边界上打一个尖尖的
NVIDIA
这个周线的确在这边有尖尖的
然后
如果我是你
我不会吃太靠上半部这边
因为这边毕竟是人家
包含这边
很大的这种套牢区域在这上面
对啊
所以如果我是吃NVIDIA的
我的想法是我想办法偏这个附近172、175这边这些是我属疫比较觉得好的点只要稍微高一点点我就不要因为这整张图
这个日线图
它发生了位阶在比较偏高
它没有在这种
刚刚这种下沙
如果是下沙到这里
我会跟大家说随便吃
但是因为它在这里
会相对起来尴尬了一点
我还是觉得这个下影线不错
只是它
他现在的这个位置尴尬
就看之后我们再回来到下面的边界
注意哦
如果下一次回来的样子是这样子
假设明天
是这样子回来
不要乱低阶
这样回来就不对了
因为他太凶
又回到刚刚孙子兵法讲的
人家很凶你要干嘛
闪
闪到人家
闪到你要吃丹的左下角
是这个下引线
这样子才是对的
这样好不好
账号昨天报了
去武岭爬荷欢山主峰
哇
我要跟这位冠维同学
致敬一下
太厉害了
骑车去武岭
我光开上去我都觉得很累了
然后你还爬了荷花山主峰
我啦
我去爬那个大坑的登山步道
我脚就酸了
我就不行
从底下爬上去
我爬到中间那个可以休息的地方
我就不行了
所以太强了
我跟你说报账号
我这样跟大家讲
报账号一点都不可耻
那你要做的就只是把
把报账号的经验吸收下来
我到底是做了什么事情
让我报了账号
然后我做了什么检讨
我这边我旁边叫一个东西
我要找一个跟一个网友的留言
然后那个留言呢
超
他传讯息给我
这是一个我们这边蛮资深的同学
他说他第一次出京
然后他出京后很开心
然后我有录在那个影片里趁机给大家
我有录在给那个同学的影片里面他说这个他是一位我们这边资深的网友他现在也在线上
来
然后他说
他整理了一下
一笔一笔去整理他当初打的单子
所以你可不可以回去检讨一下
你当初打什么单
检讨一下
他说
看才发现有些真的是当下被吸进去
那他说看完了这张表很明显叫他乖乖的打什么
打边界二或标准图
那他的统计在这边我放大给大家看
那这是他的统计
来注意看黄色这几个
打标准图的胜率
打边界二的胜率
边界二的胜率
标准图的胜率
然后猜的猜的胜率
哇
这一天打标准图出手三次0
对不对
这样
所以这些
这个整个整个交易记录下来
你看到什么
就是他刚刚讲的结论
与其在那边东摸摸西摸摸
我不如做这些就够了
有没有
那我用这个提供出来
刚好是给刚刚说爆掉的这位同学
你能不能够去找到你爆掉的那个点在哪里
你是可能可能是跟老婆吵架
我最近的那个短影片才有嘛
你可能是跟老婆吵架
你可能是是刚刚有一笔亏损过度交易
还是你是凹单大单还是什么
你去找一下你的交易记录
他其实就是你下一次复活最大的关键
你能不能够调整掉这些东西
这样
那边界二就是这个
边界二就是
就是一个点就是这样子
一个点两个点破这边吃
我就是刚刚那个那个谁
AT这个图刚好就是边界二的概念
这个这个这个市场来到这边
打出边界的有一个点两个点破隔壁
就是这种东西
这叫边界二
所以你看同学他很深刻的去做的这件事情
他第一次出京很开心
这个出京之后有没有可能说
因为拿到出京可能心态又跑掉
又觉得好想赚钱起脑袋要跑掉
跑到金錢上 有可能
那有爆 沒關係
那你就要知道說我
我可能不是技術出問題
但是是我的什麼
我的腦袋太想要賺錢
哦 太想賺錢
來 你就被
你就被
來 你就被誘惑到了
孫子兵法專門就是
他知道你很想賺錢
他就誘惑你賺錢
讓你幹嘛
让你乱掉然后就被对方拿走了
有没有
对啊
所以
市场上面
谁的心情能够平平稳稳
赚钱也这样子
赔钱也这样
就是那个王建民的扑克脸
就是这样
所以大家会说王建民的心态
很厉害
他不管是被打拳也打也好
还是三振对方也好
他的脸都是默默的
他也不笑
也不怎么样
也不生气
他就是默默的
他讲话也是这样子
这才是厉害的地方
因为他就说我就专注在下一个对手
下一个打者就好了
被打拳内打是刚刚的事情
我就把下一球投好这样就好
对啊
谁在市场上越急躁
然后越想赚钱
你的钱就会很快速的飞到对面去
飞到像这个
像这个川普这种人去这样
不是川普,孙子
好不好
我刚刚看旁边在讲Circle
Circle的周线应该很美
它好像是做虚拟货币的
来来来,同样的概念
你看哦,周线,两个周线长这样
我们可以期待的是下一周往这边走的几率就变高了
这样,因为它很明显
下不去,两周都下不去
对啊,而且日线其实
其实日线在这里有一个这种边界可以让你看
对我觉得这不错
但是现在的位置尴尬
所以可能要等他看有没有回来的地方
Microsoft
Microsoft前几天的边界也是一样的概念
你说老鱼错过了怎么办
来你都不用急
这个地方还没有经过任何的由上往下的测试
如果这边测试成功
那是不是就變成這個慣性就就開始往這邊走了对不对那个Peter说60k还有破底板对啊
这60k我只能说漂亮
漂亮到不行
很凶
长脚长脚
就是这里
所以你不要被图形给困住
那个长了下影线或长了上影线
它其实就是在告诉你
告诉你市场在这边在干嘛而已
Oxy
这什么东西啊
石油
好我们看一下
如果你没有讲我就用日线来看
哇日线卡在中间
目前是在中间
前几天的日线不错
这个边界
只不过这个边界
可能只有更短线直接摸的才有办法
或是你要用周线的
我看一下
我看我都会退成这样子
周线整个样子看一下
我知道这个边界
如果你是用纯周线的交易计划
那其实就是41块
41.48
管花多少
买在40
很好啊
那就是报着
就是这些地方都是你的点
如果你买在
等一下你买在40
是更早以前的40吗
是这里吗
如果买在这边应该就很漂亮
是说如果你买40
你应该是用边界2的角度切入
一直到现在这附近才有标准图的概念
就是这里
这个标准图的概念
我的交易系统是怎么误出来的
好问题
赔出来的
你相信吗
各种赔就是
这边做赔那边做赔
这边做赔这边做赔
然后慢慢的
慢慢的检讨
这样这样做会赔钱
这样追会撞墙
这样干嘛干嘛这样
你问我标准图
我其实就是有某一年
就很无聊
我都在赔钱然后想说奇怪
那些涨上去的股票怎么我都抓不到
可恶
那我想说那涨上去之前
有没有什么固定的样子
然后我就回头去看
怎么涨上去了以前的股票怎么有一些这样子的图形然后就上去了然后有一些是这样子互换以后
就出去了
像前一段时间的QS
QS的周线
周线
这里
这个大边界这里
本来上不去的东西
回来了
就出去了
这样
所以我就是那时候研究了好一段时间
然后才发现
怎么图形都这样
慢慢慢慢才变成眼前
大家现在所看到的这个交易法
中间怎么变得
坦白讲我不知道了
好不好
Siri 周线
还有什么
跳空怎么解盘
来给这位认为解盘的同学
我们先试着把解盘这句话拿掉
我从来不解盘
解盘的意思是这个解的这个字
它的意思是
我知道这个盘面在干嘛
我看透了
甚至我去猜对方的意图是什么
那从我的角度我不解盘
我就只是看盘
我观察
我用我的眼睛看
所以我在看盘的时候
我完全没有用我的左脑
左脑是掌管语言跟思考
我就是笨笨的
用我的眼睛看
各位问我问题都一样
用眼睛看
这里图形上哪边
做什么事情
所以我们先试着
把解盘两个字拿掉
那你说遇到跳空怎么办
来
小那
遇到跳空
来来来给大家看一下
这是我
这边被打了不赔
我后面这边就
这边被打不赔之后
然后还吃了几次
然后就没了
对
所以你看我这边
我都有吃
都被洗掉
对
那为什么
我就没有认真的继续做
这一天我好像是什么
我要去打球还是干嘛
反正我忘记了
这样
好不好
然后
我要讲什么
小娜跳空有跳空吗
小娜有跳空吗小娜没有跳空啊还是你讲的是指那天从这边直接跳上来的这里
你指的是指这个吗
你指的是指哪一个
这个缺口吗
这个吗
这个跳空很简单
你知道吗
来我跟各位说
跳空的概念
这边跳到这边
代表力量很强
对吧
那我不会在跳上去的过程中
就直接去跟着追
那如果这个缺口
像眼前的这个一样
我们回到当天
当天第一个跳空长这样子
来各位
上一线上一线上一线
你脑袋里想什么
是如果行情走到这里来
这里就是一道压力支撑的边界
反正这个缺口
如果有被补起来
这缺口不大
才这样看100点而已
100点的小
以percentage来讲
非常非常的小
所以如果有补
那我就可以把这边列为
我的出手的边界
可以
那如果缺口很远
如果从这边直接跳
下一个点到这里
缺口这么远
那我就不会想那么多
第一个
这边直接跳到这里很强
但是来到这边我就不追了
我会慢慢的给它好一段时间
整理跟观察这个缺口
它补什么样子
如果像这样子
在这里就补起来
它底下这边没有补了
难道这样
我可能就会下单在这个地方
在这里
因为我看到破底翻
在小10k
我可能就按了
这样理解了吗
好不好
所以缺口的概念是
不要单纯说缺口就一定是强还是弱
我要看的是
缺口出现行情来这边
它长什么样子
好不好
我用ICT吗
对不起
我不知道什么是ICT
我用我的交易法
用很久了
十年了
这个标准图这样做
应该已经有十年
应该有了
以上了
所以ICT是很后面
人家才跟我说
国外有人用ICT
什么
对啊
有人说什么
什么small money什么的我不知道
反正我后来有去看了一下
ICT他们的交易法
说真的大同小异
只是名称不一样
他的专有名词好多哦
那我的个人是我的脑袋很烂
我记不了那么多的专有名词
这里是这样是那个英文的专有名词
这个也是这样
太累了
我就看图就好了
图就不用有名词
就看图就好了
就这样
哎呀
好不好
台股也用这个吗
没有这个是美股的
这是专门做美股的
这里唯一一个跟台股有关系的是
台积电在美国上架的ADR
那个TSM他的代号
这是做专门做美股
以及美股期货
美股的选择权
反正你美国相关的股票
都可以在这边做的软体
好吧
我自己的
我自己的那个什么
的股票是在台湾的券商买的
这样
好吗
盈透盈透盈透证券
有同学说我的trading view
哎呀这个点比我刚刚吃的点好
但是我已经锁住了
就这样子吧
最后这个
上周问的这周还没讲
是哦 sorry
不要急
如果是上周我一样会跟你讲
因为这是周线上周我会跟你讲说
这个上面这样下来
这边平平的不要急
那现在这一周反而是好事
因为他刚发生这个
你等他一下
他刚发生破底
你等他这个会好多了
这样子好不好
所以你其实你等他
你明天礼拜五嘛
你就等他个一天
周限收这样子以后
你下一周的打击区
再来慢慢的做交易
都比这个好多了
忍忍忍
这样好不好
然后原油60k是标准图吗
原油
我们看一下原油的60k
60k吗
我有看到原油吗
60k
标准图吗
不行不行
不要在这里做
来来来
就算它有互换
我现在是用纯60k的角度
我不管你5分K做什么
这个东西在60k的位阶里面它偏哪里它偏上面他偏上面这边不要,这整件事情这整件事情如果发生在这里
比如说这里
这样子,整理整理整理
刚上去的这里,哦这样子,这个我会给过
这样,但是他太靠
太靠这边了,反而我不喜欢
甚至他如果是在下面
叠下来
整理整理这里,哦那这个就好多了
好不好
然后NQ发生什么事
NQ还好啦
这随便的震荡
这才多少点而已
不用理他啦
不用理他
好不好
SMR
是可以观察的两条线下缘吗
9921前面讲过咯
前面讲过咯
smr 我看一下
sm
这什么东西呢
这个
new scale
你要问的是问什么
两条线吗
应该是日线吧
日线
我这样看
可以
可以耶
日线也是周线的好边界
我们用这支股票拿来当刚刚孙子兵法的很多案例
这边有没有这一周追在50块52块55块的人这一周
有追在这边的人撞这个墙壁
然后被关门放狗
全死光了
买在55的现在停损在19块
哭死
对吧
那现在来来来
现在是做多的军队走很累
还是做空的军队
来到做多的大本营
很累的地方
哦 看得出来吧
那我们是不是就在这个大本营的地方
等待对方变累
那对方累了会有什么迹象
会有这种下影线的样子
长在这种地方
所以开始出来了
有没有
你也可以不用急
因为他才刚开始日线刚开始而已
所以这边会一些震荡是很正常的事情边界会慢慢越来越清楚我只是用这个是一个很好的孙子兵法的案例我不认识这只股票
但是它就是这样子
然后甚至
他有说在火工篇里面
他说如果这个火很强
风往那边吹
你就试着乘势让它追击
例如说这里
这一根K棒这么强势
这一根
这一根这么强
他是不是突破这边
对不对
那就把这一段给翻亚当
你就
你不用追
但是你可以不用走
就上去把这个力量给做完
哇
开心愉快
你说老鱼这个也很强势啊
对啊
很强势啊
但是他所处的位置是
新一段
亚当的地方
你心中就要有底啦
对吧
这一根这么大根
来我们翻一下
锁住
翻翻
可以棒对起来
他说来到这里
而且容易遇到大震荡了
所以可能这个已经喷完了
所以你也不用追
你要就是买在底部
对吧
然后不用追
你等上面
假设弱掉了
你至少也是不赔
对不对
所以这个的周线很漂亮
有破底翻的概念
有
那你说对方有没有累了
他们慢慢在变累
顺便跟大家科普一下
一个市场
任何一只股票
原油 期货 外汇都一样
要从很凶狠的样子
变成
不凶狠
变成变类的样子
它的K棒会从大的K棒变小K棒
你看一下
本周的K棒
是不是大K棒
本周终于停下来变小K棒
日线也一样
你看哦
这里K棒大大的
这里连续几根K棒
是不是K棒开始变小了一些
包含现在也是
所以这个区域
我还不敢抓出精准的点
但是那个区域
K棒就是变小了
所以我会建议大家
如果你是做周线
等一下
你不用急
你等它
它才第一次周线的停顿
等一下
但是开始可以观察
观念是这样
好不好
有人问以太币
好耶
我们看一下以太
因为我没有做
所以已知证明放在所有地方都可以用
我随便开一个交易所这我随便开的以太币日线空方满足,小10k找图啊对,我的黄金,好,赶快讲一讲黄金
对对对,空方满足,等一下
没有空方满足,空方满足是在
如果空方满足是这样吧
对吧
除非你的空方满足是15k或5分k的
你是要做多
是吗
你会讲空方满足
代表你是要做多
对不对
不要做多
这个很明显的边界
人家一堆支撑
然后一大根很凶的下来
你有看到任何的
任何的涨多跌少的惯性吗
没有啊
你看这里
跌多涨少
跌多涨多跌少
这里有啊
然后就上去了
但是眼前没有啊
好不好
来最后讲一下我自己
今天的黄金
黄金
不是M&Q我在干嘛
这个
来这是我今天的黄金
那给大家看一下
我大致上
在这边
四单三口八口两口
测试测试测试
然后呢
这边
被洗掉一些
这边好像我记得是几个不赔
我其实忘记细节
但是没有赔很多
因为我就是上去了
拉个不赔
然后就很快被洗掉
这里
我加在这里
加15加15
上去
短短出出出
我今天在这边呈现短线的状态
一方面是我知道
是冷门交易时间
第二个
当时是美股
而今天的美股是没有开盘休假
所以我心里想要是好这样子
然后这里底下在这里
买很快就被卖掉
后面我在这边出手是在这个地方
这边加加加加加
这一段是赚钱的
这里好不好
这里出去出掉
10 10 10
所以我这边出了一次
两个10出在这
最后一个10出在这
我没有出在最高点
这样
对不对
然后接下来
这边这个
你看买在4183停损在这边
短短的我都手很短很短
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕